for House Speaker Newt Gingrich became
one of Donald Trump's most prominent and
outspoken surrogates in the 2016
presidential campaign the Republican was
once a presidential hopeful himself he's
written more than two dozen books the
latest is called understanding Trump he
writes to really grasp Trump
you must understand his doctrine in his
psychology the collection of attitudes
and methods he used to achieve success
that doctrine is fast its aggressive
disruptive and confounding to the unwary
Gingrich joins us at the table to
discuss we're going to talk about your
book in just a sec because you call
Donald Trump one of the most remarkable
individuals to occupy the White House
everybody agrees with you on that but
we'll get to that in a second let's talk
about Jeff Sessions word on the street
is that you were very good at giving
advice well Jim advised the advice is
good or not I'm not sure that's a word
about you mr. Gingrich would you give
mr. sessions the advice to be more
forthcoming with his meetings with
Russian officials sure of course and I
think he will be he has not been would
you say up to this point well I you know
his his answer was that he misunderstood
the question and you think that's true
probably I think he originally was asked
had you met with the Russians in your
campaign role and he said no now he'd
met him with him twice as a u.s. senator
and the truth is as it turned out from a
number of his critics that all sorts of
US senators routinely meet with the
Russian ambassador I mean it's it's a
courtesy of them I think you're going to
find in this latest allegation that the
Russian ambassador was one of ninety
people in a room and then wrote home and
said I met with senator sessions today
because it made him look good but in
fact there's no evidence that they ever
met except maybe walking through the
Mayflower at a reception this is that
reportedly third undisclosed meeting
that the former FBI director told
Senators about that may be archeology
that's based apparently on and this is
all hearsay but it's based apparently on
an intercept of the Russian ambassador
saying I you know I met with him well
pictures of the actual reception don't
show the Russian investor anywhere near
sessions and sessions is milling around
with 90 people and there's no evidence
that there was a private meeting you
think the president is considering
firing Robert Muller no why don't you
think that why why why don't you think
that well because I think the president
actually is pretty confident that
ultimately this is all going to come out
and they were in the wash and ultimately
he's still going to be president and
this stuff's all going to go away but I
think I think the president
I know because he and I have talked
about a little bit when was the last
time you talked to her last night
wait a minute last night yeah about he
called me because I have been very clear
about the fact that Muller hiring for
Democrats is for his first floor
apartment attorneys are all Democrats
one of them worked for the Clinton
Foundation he Penta couldn't find a
single proton paternity to hire and I
just think that that's a rigged game and
I think that it's a mistake to pretend
that this is going to be some neutral
investigation you think they would say
they're anti Trump well they're all for
gave money to the Democrats the Justice
Department itself of its contributions
ninety seven percent went is it perhaps
septic that they're the best attorneys
you can find because they had long
written you're suggesting that in the
entire country there are no Republican
attorneys that Muller animator jesting
that perhaps the one he's hired so far
may be the best he could find I just
think that I love the way you're saying
to me by that you had a piece a couple
minutes ago on the president being
assassinated okay we had a so-called
comedian holding the president's bloody
head in this kind of environment I don't
give the benefit of the doubt to
somebody who can only hire Democrats the
claims that we ought to trust him
yeah but it was a Shakespeare play
though mr. Gingrich okay that's a great
plan I will commit and I recommend to
liberals that they look at what Marta it
wasn't accurate right well that is okay
just let me just ask you about your
change of tune because in May you
tweeted that the Bob Muller is a superb
choice to be special counsel his
reputation is impeccable for honesty and
integrity the media should calm down
right and and now you're questioning
whether he's going to be fair or not
what is it well three things changed my
mind
the first was commies astonishing
comment last week and this which totally
an understanding Trump in the whole
point of with the world Trump's in the
middle of call me last week says of the
enormous arrogance I decided that I
would leak so that we would set up a
special counsel now the idea of the FBI
director by the way Muller is one of his
closest friends the idea the FBI
director would manipulate
the entire system through a leak in
order to get a special counsel to me set
off alarm bells second as I said a
minute ago
Muller's first four hires one work for
the Clinton Foundation all four donated
to the Democrats one of them has a
terrible record of hiding information
from defendants and was repudiated nine
zero by the Supreme Court these are not
the kind of people that make me feel
comfortable in this environment that
we're going to get a serious honest
investing so you want an you want an
independent counsel or our daughters
have have have molars that commit that
he's going to hire as many Republicans
as he hires Democrats let's just start
with transparency could we have as many
pro Trump lawyers as we have anti Trump
lawyers I don't talk you talk to Trump
last night did you say that I thought
you said you talked to him last night
yeah I don't think that's big news I
mean well I I didn't know that I didn't
tweet it I described how his mindset is
now people say isolated people say
no no he's under siege people say look
to be a typical author let me Lisa as
part of these now wrote understanding
Trump is to help people understand Trump
Trump is a man of enormous resilience
here's a man who and and the opening of
his book the art of the comeback which
in some ways is psychologically more
interesting than the art of the deal
where he talks about he's about to go
bankrupt personally he's about to go
bankrupt corporately Ivana's called to
say she wants a divorce and he says you
know I could either get really depressed
or I could figure out how to come back
now that's Trump I talked to him two or
three weeks before the election he was
supposedly down ten points and he said
with an enormous intensity I always win
after the Access Hollywood taping point
out that he said that he said three
times to me I always win he said I'm not
quite sure how yet but by Election Day I
want you to know now I think his
attitude he's now president no you said
no Newt you say he aims high and
accomplishes what people say is
impossible right and he has done a lot
of that already let me ask you then
about the business of legislating I mean
he he promised to help the Forgotten
people he has a Republican Congress as
you know you were incredibly productive
in the first hundred days
what's wrong with the legislative
process I think that this is one of the
areas where
Trump is going to have to ultimately
really rethink the whole approach and
really look become much more like Reagan
in reaching out to the country and
building waves of support they've been
fairly productive in smaller public in
Congress well but that's that's a
misnomer look Trump had a hostile
takeover of the Republican Party
followed by a hostile takeover of
Washington I mean and I think he
underestimated how really complicated
this was and again part of the reason I
wrote understanding Trump is because I'm
sitting there thinking the guy that I
watched and can study pretty carefully
is very different from a traditional
politician having said all of that what
would worried about what kind of
development would worry you about his
survival in office no I look he's not
gonna get him pay via Bloomberg speech
I've decided no Mayor Bloomberg said the
other day in the end Trump's gonna get
reelected now this truly horrified
liberals I think he'll be there for
eight years I think in his heart he
knows he'll be there for eight years yes
as you know because you've covered this
year old career the power of a president
to survive is unbelievable and I think
Trump is learning I think he learns
everyday a little bit look look at his
foreign trip which was a tour de force I
mean that's as good as any president in
my lifetime well some people argue that
the Saudi Arabia part was good but the
European part was not good the European
Party accomplished exactly what he
intended we also say the presidency is a
work in progress
absolutely and will be a beacon until
the day he leaves mr. speaker it's good
to see the book is called understanding
Trump it's on sale today